Jim: Jim! Jim!
Jim, come on!
I've got the shot!
I've got it!
What is it, Jim?
Jim, come on
The Detective: Hey!
Jim: Oh jeez, oh jeez
The Detective: Hey! Who the hell are you?!
You listen! This is a crime scene!
You better hope I don't find you or I'll lock you up myself!
Jim: Let's go, let's go
Stay low
My name is Jim, I am here with my associate, Jim...
Reporting at the scene of the crime.
As you can see...
Uh, this is where a body...
once resided.
Lived right here.
Wait a sec...
Jim, come on,
Stay low
Ah,
a shooty
*grunts*
I don't know what that means, but it means bad.
*gasp*
These must be the murderers. Jim,
this is profound in the least, so
*sniff*
We're in grave danger. And if we...
Even mess up, for even a..
We'll be next.
Back to you Jim. Alright, let's go, let's go,
*Jims' footsteps*
Jim: Jim